AJA HAMMERLY: Did
you know that you
can create an instance group
template from a container
image?
I'll show you how.
Start at the Compute section
on the cloud console.
Click Instance Groups,
Create Instance Group.
Name your group.
Select a location.
And under Instance Definition,
choose Create a New Container
Instance Template.
Name your template.
Select a machine type.
And then put in the path
to your container image.
My container image is on
Google Cloud Registry.
You can select a boot disk
type, set up any ports,
and turn on HTTP and HTTPS
traffic if you need to.
Click Save and Continue.
Choose the number of instances.
And you can set up auto
healing if you'd like.
Now click Create.
Once your group is created, you
can click Instance Templates
and find your template there.
I hope you get a
chance to try this out.